there's a saying that i usually dislike
tell me if you've heard it before
truth is stranger than fiction my
problem with it is that most of the time
the people saying it
haven't read much fiction because
fiction can be pretty strange
but every now and then something happens
which gives this tired old saying
new life and it makes me rethink it this
is one of those stories
a story of a nom police forces around
the world have made hundreds of arrests
as part of a major sting
targeting organized crime networks
criminal bosses were tricked
into using an fbi run encrypted
messaging app
officers were able to read millions of
messages in real time
describing murder plots mass drug
importation plans
and lots of other schemes 18 months at
least of capturing this criminal
activity so this is really a proud day
for the good guys
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla
and i would submit to you that if you
look today you'll find
hundreds of articles telling you about a
global sting operation that led to 800
arrests
700 premises searched and maybe you'll
even hear of sopia kong the ninja
warrior competitor
that she was even one of the arrested
with 154 grams of walter white seized
maybe you've heard that something called
encrypted messaging was involved but
i'm gonna tell you that's just the
surface of this thing
the idea of infiltrating the underworld
with a fake privacy phone
is said to have started over a couple of
beers between the australian police and
the fbi in 2018.
kind of makes sense right that's where
all good ideas start see the big news
going around was the criminal underworld
had a privacy hole in the market
and the police well they wanted to
capitalize on it this is because one of
the criminal network's
main communication methods had just
totally collapsed
obviously the underworld kind of relies
on constant communication some of it
very long distance to conspire to
launder money
traffic drugs do business etc so they've
turned to
sophisticated encryption to keep their
plans secret from the cops now
you may have heard of a few apps like
these apps like
signal which are devoted to encrypted
messaging but for some
criminals that isn't enough nearly all
phones have gps
cameras microphones in them which are
all liabilities
so as a result a small industry has
opened up to help those people who want
true privacy from law enforcement enter
the privacy file let's pull up the board
here
these are phones purely designed for
privacy they have their gps disabled
most of them have
a lot of apps disabled and they route
messages through proxies before
delivering them so your location is sort
of always
unknown and some of these phones don't
even allow you to message anyone who
doesn't share
a privacy phone like yours further
securing your communication
now one of the companies that filled
this need was known as
phantom secure phantom secure was a
canadian-based company that was
operated by ceo vincent ramos the
company had it all
secure messaging it even created a
remote kill switch
that could wipe the device's data
remotely which was
hugely popular you know in case your
device got compromised by the cops
and apparently it worked because
documents show that multiple times law
enforcement got a hold of these phones
they'd find them wiped now as a quick
caveat if it seems like i've been
insinuating here that everyone who's
interested in privacy phones
are criminals that's obviously not
intended and not true
there are a million reasons to want
privacy and i support encryption but in
the case of
phantom secure it's more specifically
was kind of a drug thing okay vincent
ramos literally
told undercover agents he made the phone
for drug trafficking
this is actually a screenshot of an
undercover meeting with vincent
seated in a couch trying to reassure
drug dealers who were skeptical about
the phone
he apparently told them but yeah that's
exactly what i'm saying right
we made it phantom secure we made it
specifically for this
too meaning drug trafficking this
admission gave him a one-way ticket to
being arrested
and eventually flipping as a state
witness in exchange for the hope
of a more lenient sentence which meant
that everyone who had previously used
phantom secure
were suddenly left without a privacy
phone they couldn't use the phone
network anymore and they were looking
for a new device
to rely on so now we can go back to this
conversation between the fbi and
australia over beers they
knew that there was this gap in the
market the loss of phantom secure had
been huge for criminals
and a plan emerged to capitalize on this
they decided that they would create
their own privacy phone and they would
sell it
to criminals and track the messages now
this game isn't anything new
it's actually something called a
honeypot and it's common within sting
operations
law enforcement will use some kind of a
device
to bring in criminals and then catch
them right this is
famously bait car was a car that could
be remotely turned off by the police
it was attracted you know criminals who
stole cars
and then they would catch them and lock
them up but in this case the honeypot
is a secure phone called the anom phone
the anom phone company built itself like
a privacy phone like
phantom secure it looked like a phone
acted like a phone
but it couldn't do most things it wasn't
like
other phones obviously instead to use it
you had to go to the calculator app
installed on the phone
and type in a special code which lets
you in the app
now at this point and maybe i'm crazy i
think the
criminal should have gotten suspicious
but maybe that's just hindsight talking
right this was a well-designed app it
looks good as you can see
it was even designed by a drug dealer
who had flipped to work for the fbi
and the way this app worked was that
every message would be secretly sent to
the police
alongside the receiver so that the cops
could basically watch criminals talk to
each other without them knowing
and slowly they distributed these phones
through a network of criminals
some of which who used to operate and
sell the phantom securum network
and each time a new criminal got it that
would then serve as later connections to
sell
their people on it over the course of
three years 12
000 devices had eventually been sold to
300 criminal syndicates
which is insane and basically the cops
had created their own little thriving
phone business
and that's actually one of the hilarious
parts of this whole story is that
the cops are selling phones like a phone
company
to criminals and selling even
subscription services
like you literally had to pay a monthly
fee for this and the phone itself wasn't
cheap either it was 2500 bucks
a piece all of this is going back to the
police
which is kind of hilarious when you
think about it like you're paying the
people
who are about to arrest you and it
allowed the cops
unprecedented access into the underworld
and a nom
of course was a huge hit not only with
the cops but also with users
soon the messages began to roll in
messages like this
think he got it you're dreaming you
reckon what did he offer it to you for
the guy responds with a bunch of what
appears to be cocaine
with batman on it now there are tons of
other messages like this
but most of them have the grammar of a
five-year-old
and also they're pretty repetitive
they're all sort of talking about
drugs or violence of some kind i'll sort
of
save you uh some of the the low res
text messages real quick and get to the
point the cops start
busting these guys drug shipments left
and right for example
one of the cocaine shipments they busted
was found among
pineapples who had been cored out to put
the cocaine in in another bust they
found 3
000 pounds of cocaine hidden in a
shipment of
tuna cans of all things i can only
imagine how confusing it must have been
for the criminals at this point to like
be planning these things in secret with
these secure phones
and suddenly the cops are just showing
up knowing everywhere you are
and you're calling your buddy like did
you hide it in the pineapples though
800 arrests two tons of math
eight tons of cocaine 22 tons of
marijuana
250 firearms 48 million dollars and six
tons of chemicals that are used to make
other drugs and stuff
law enforcement also says they thwarted
something like a hundred
murder plots which is completely insane
and shows just how productive this sting
operation
was the only thing that sucks is that
the fact that you and i know about this
means that the criminals know about it
too it's an open secret
and criminals will be much more careful
using privacy phones now but there's one
last
funny wrinkle i need to tell you about
if it seems sort of unbelievable that
none of the criminals suspected anything
actually someone did an anonymous
blogger
released a post called a nom encrypted
scam
exposed the blogger's name was can you
guess 67 and on march
29th he wrote this article detailing how
a nom
is actually not a secure phone at all
and he compares it to
cipher which is another privacy phone
company
and showed how a nom is unsecured it
links to various google servers and it's
easy to pull
ip information which obviously you don't
want out there
and this all happened at a completely
critical
moment for this sting because the big
sting hadn't happened yet it was
a lot of you know data collection
watching
letting the phones sort of proliferate
around the underworld
according to the us attorney only in the
last 48 hours of the investigation
did the plan get most of its results 500
of the 800 arrests
came in the last 48 hours of the giant
sting
and this one post called it out three
months
beforehand but here's the insane thing
and again this is where
this story is hard to believe this guy
can you guess
67 he didn't get it all right he of
course
pointed out that the phones were on
secure and went through like amazon
servers
google servers but he had no idea why
and in possibly the most hilarious twist
of irony of all time
he finishes the blog post by saying that
he reported a nom
to law enforcement needless to say
shortly after he reported this the post
was deleted
and the plan stayed safe three months
later of course the massive sting went
down
and i believe it's going to go down as
one of the most legendary moments of
police intelligence work in decades but
it was
almost unraveled by a guy who thought
he was simply exposing a scam the story
of a nom
is a fascinating look into the lives not
only of the criminal underworld
but also our intelligence agencies who
seemingly will go to any length
to get by encryption services and get
into this underworld where they can find
and catch
criminals this operation not only hurt
organized crime what i love about it is
that i believe it serves as a reminder
that sometimes the cops aren't as blind
as people want to believe
sometimes they're a step ahead listening
in on your conversations